huit mille huit cents habitants
commerçants industriels artisans et
membres des professions libérales 350
fonctionnaires et retraités mille
ouvriers employés 14 cents premiers 500
jeunes de moins de 20 ans l'âge ips a
racheté le grand café pollet en 1961 il
a ouvert la jeunesse de la ville
c'est à dire la partie la plus nombreuse
de la population d'aujourd'hui entre 16
et 21 ans 500 étudiants haïtiens 550
demoiselles de magasins apprentis
ouvriers
c'est de l'appétit à 7h30 quand on est
sans manger
vous êtes ouvriers l'un et l'autre
explique m on travaille sur du bois ont
fait des fleurs du ruhl de l'ancien
local jean louis saez rustique quel âge
as-tu 15 ans tu t'appelles comment
pierre aucun on t'appelle du doubs jouer
tu es connu si oui ça se passe souvent
là tu viendrais qu'en même temps on
pense que tous les jours à quelle heure
à cette heure ci quoique les fausses or
j'ai regardé la télé et du travail oui
dis moi ce que tu fais sophie gines est
un conte moderne de quitter l'école
depuis combien de temps
mois dernier
dubois un coup quelquefois ici tu bois
d'achelles raconte muscat sec un panache
et non la vie moderne lycéens le jeudi à
deux heures de l'après midi il y à 724
interne venus des environs
après midi entre toujours des copains on
ce matin leur table facilement ce rendez
vous êtes sûr de trouver quelqu'un oui
toujours quelqu'un à côté de m
c'est à dire des gens de notre âge oui
mes camarades durs mais vous vous êtes
jamais mis à côté de quelqu'un vous ne
connaissez pas paul et qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait que la place y'a pas de maison
de disques pour vous cette petite ville
c'est le type de ville selon votre coeur
parfois on a relevé mme khemiri si
petite fille de 18 ans 20 ans neeve et
si ça vient votre ancien jambes fumer la
cigarette on aurait crié au scandale
écoutez ses yeux c'est mieux parce qu
ils exagèrent l'ancien gunner à l'appui
leur folie beaucoup de jeunes filles
je sais plus amère sauget c'est plus la
même pas tout ça mais non extrême en
sortir même chose aux plus avertis il ya
moins d'un mois maximum et 20 19,79
décider du poulet finale du pôle est
depuis longtemps malheureusement c'était
combien de temps toujours depuis
toujours mais j'ai l'impression vous
parlez pas avec les autres personnes
c'est une belle occasion mais voyez vous
ce qu'il y avait beaucoup de jeunes
marins alors les jeunes ne comprennent
plus je croyais et de sa mort quand des
balles se mord cadre le courrier qui
vous comprennent plus si quand même un
peu mais c'est plus pareil hein je n'ai
plus la même ambiance quand même parce
que dans le temps maintenant s'ils
étaient bien gentille mais seulement la
clientèle c'est pas pareil
oui c'était des bourgeois quitter les
petits vieux qui n'en voulait faire un
billard et puis jetés et bourgeois qui
était la cité des halles on avait fait
plus pas l'oeil de biche et des
recharges qui vous venez ici au passé de
la soirée avec
les chiffres f et qu'à cet univers il
fallait qu'on le remette publie sous les
pieds ici c'était comme un lieu un lieu
réservé c'était une sorte de club il y
avait les tables de jeu par exemple où
l'on voyait parfois sur la table une
ferme toute entière j'ai souvenance
d'une ferme qui espérait qu on jouait
très fort naturellement avec les jetons
puisque c'était interdit
une ferme entière s'est joué une fois
sur cette table là là bas c'était la
table mais il a perdu les eaux depuis ce
matin 4000 ou 5000 francs à s'arrêter
quand il sent épiée chasseurs tranquille
et qui livrait sa vie lié ses enfants
puis après
non
le sujet reviendra toujours bas
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut ce tranquille dans la vie
mené bien sa barque il y aura bien un
nul et vierge demande au cimetière
musulman petrov qui pratique aux
demandes et hippie le hippie neuf
châteaux du monde c'est parce qu'un jour
je suis revenu d'angleterre avec des
habits des fleurs des fleurs dans les
cheveux des clochettes on appelle le
hippie
muse abdi un peu
expliquez moi ça
ses livres j'aime beaucoup les fleurs
j'aime beaucoup l'amour
j'aime la philosophie
[Musique]